a big story this afternoon it is crunch
time up at the state capitol today is
the end of the legislative session with
plenty of work going right down to the
wire job one finishing the budget
politics now host John langler is live
in Carson City as lawmakers hustle John
to finish on time
yeah Brian and David they're hustling
right now in fact so far today it's been
a Relentless stream of amended bills
being introduced closed door
negotiations taking place Hasty votes on
the floor all in an effort again to
finish the budget by midnight Republican
Governor Joe Lombardo as you may know
threatened to veto any budget that
doesn't include his priorities he has
five main ones before the session
started now there has been some
compromise the last couple of days to do
with a magnet school transportation
there was a crime bill that was approved
earlier today but right now the
governor's opportunity scholarships
office of school choice they are not
included negotiation between the
legislature and the governor's office
have taken place all day the overriding
question is whether a special session is
needed from lawmakers we spoke with
opinion is mixed
to pass the capital Improvement plan
budget it takes a two-thirds majority
and I can tell you right now our caucus
is United and not passing that until we
have some of our our priorities
addressed I know our leadership has been
in many many discussions over the last
couple of days making sure that we can
get out of this building on time so I'm
betting my money that that'll happen
aside from the budget there are two
major tax incentive proposals that are
still unsettled we've talked about them
a lot that's the 380 million dollar tax
package the incentive for that A's
baseball stadium and the four billion
dollar deal to build movie studios in
Las Vegas there's a growing feeling here
among the lawmakers the lobbyists you
talk to that those may not make the cut
and they might actually need a special
session for that we'll certainly see
where that goes one way or another
though the legislative session ends at
midnight tonight they are on the floor
right now we'll get back in there see
where things go and keep you updated All
Night Long live in Carson City John
langler 8 news now all right John thank
you for that some other things we're
watching up in Carson City a water
conservation Bill going and giving
powers to snwa to limit water users
waiting on a decision now from the
governor a bill to require insurance
companies to cover gender surgery still
needs a final vote in the state senate
and so does a bill introduced at the
last minute which creates a 100 million
dollar fund for homeless Services also a
bill lifting the medical malpractice
lawsuit cap from 350 000 to 750 000 just
waiting on a final vote in the assembly